-Thank you very much.
So, I'm originally from
Wisconsin.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Thank you. Yeah.
That's why I always have a look
on my face like, "Holy cow.
My Adderall just kicked in."
And it's a little too strong.
My friends tell me that I'm
extra, and I think that's good.
My friends are always
telling me to tone it down.
I ran into my friend on the
street the other day
and I go, "Hi!"
And he goes, "No!"
He's like, "Don't do that."
I think that's why
I don't have any kids, you know?
I think even my swimmers
are too nice.
I think they swim
right over to the egg,
and they're like,
"I don't want to be a bother."
I'm just going to hang out
over here in the friend zone.
If you want to make a baby,
ram into me."
Sorry.
Yeah. I'm a feminist.
I love women.
I used to live in one.
Yeah. Oh, you too? Okay, yeah.
Yeah, I'm not
bitter that I got evicted.
But I think that that's
one of the reasons
why I am the way that I am.
I grew with a hardcore feminist
mom, which is great.
But when I was 10-years-old,
she'd take me to these rallies.
They'd be like, "Men are bad."
And I'd be like,
"I am becoming one.
Crap.
Well, I guess I'll half-ass it."
And here you have it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
I also grew up poor.
How poor was I?
We were so poor
that I had to have
hand-me-down clothing
from my mom.
Do you know how
terrible that was?
My best friend
had a leather jacket.
I had a sweatshirt
with a kitten yawning.
It said, "I don't do mornings."
My mom was like, "Do you know
what would go great with that?"
I'm like, "Yeah, karate lessons.
'Cause right now,
I'm dressed in drag,
but as a lady
approaching menopause.
Who doesn't do mornings."
I'm surprisingly straight.
I'll tell you that. Yeah.
I remember when I came out
to my parents as straight.
They were like, "Oh, okay.
We can't wait to meet
your girlfriend.
And if we never meet her,
that's okay, too.
We'll just nickname her Santa."
It's crazy to me that,
in this day and age,
people still stay the
dumbest things about sexuality.
Like, I was at the bar
the other night,
and this fella -- He goes, "Oh,
no way that you're straight."
And I go, "why?"
And he goes,
"'Cause you're so nice."
And I go, "Well, that's not
how sexuality works."
I've never heard a guy be like,
"You -- I'm taking you home
tonight, fella."
And I was like, "Well, okay.
Oh, I have no boundaries.
Third time this week.
I am so worn out
from being kind."
No, I sometimes wish that I was
a little less
of a sensitive guy.
You know, like, the other night,
I was in bed with
my girlfriend, who's female.
And she goes,
"Talk dirty to me."
And I go, "You're a person."
She goes, "What do you
want to do to me?"
And I was like,
"I'm going to get you pregnant
and then, you know,
just, like, be there for you."
Yeah. Edgy guy.
But I do think that
we need to keep making
things better for
women, 'cause let's face it --
it's ridiculous.
We're the only animal on
the planet that pretends like
the female of
our species is weak.
Have you guys ever met a woman?
Not weak at all.
No. Could you imagine ever
pretending like any other animal
was weak just because it was
the girl of that animal?
You would never be standing
on the beach going, "Oh, my God.
I can't believe that Larry
just got eaten by a girl shark."
Girls sharks be crazy.
Yeah, they're emotional eaters.
She's like, "I had a bad day.
Larry."
Then she's like,
"Why did I eat all of Larry?"
"Bridget, why didn't you
split Larry with me?
Now I feel like a sea cow."
Thank you. I'm Pete Lee.
Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Oh, my god. Oh, my god.
-Thank you.
-Amazing!
The great Pete Lee, everybody.
Follow him on Twitter
@peteleetweets.